what we experienced in 2015 that was the
first time that
something is happening and it's totally
different than than what we experienced
before 400
000 illegal migrants came to our
Southern borders and they wanted to just
come in and cross the border without any
permission and they just wanted to go to
Germany some of them wanted to stay but
many of them wanted to go to Germany
Sweden and other other countries and and
this was a point when prime minister
realized that that
you know the migration what we were
talking about it's completely different
uh from what we will experience in these
debates and and if we look around
um sub-Saharan Africa North Africa uh
Middle East Central Asia there are
millions of millions of people 10
millions and 10 millions of people
coming from overpopulated countries uh
and and they want to start a new life
somewhere and Europe that's the closest
uh continent so they want to start
without any permission they started they
want to start a new life in in Europe
so in this piece that I read that you
laid out so we talked about the
population portion of it and why you
want obviously people to have kids and
multiply and that and you know the the
topic migration is linked to that so
that that was the next one I was yeah
yeah sorry because it's it's linked to
it's linked to the idea of population
decline if if we can agree on on on that
we need people
then some of the Liberals are saying
that okay from a labor market point of
view I agree with you just open up just
open up but then
um then you lose everything what makes
you what you are because those people
who are coming they are obviously coming
from uh
from different civilizational they are
bringing in different civilizational
backgrounds what's been the general uh
immigration policy of Hungary say over
the last decade or two what's the
general if you if you want to come in or
with the migrants and the presidents you
guys are under yeah so so deep uh the
the general approach is it's it's very
simple we have experience
um neighboring countries
um ethnic hungarians or those people who
are belonging to to neighboring Nations
they they are trying to come trying to
come to Hungary legally uh we make it
possible illegally we
uh don't support that idea and and
currently we are hosting more than uh
one million Ukrainian refugees they are
our neighbors so uh so we have the
humanitarian responsibility for help
have them uh but what we experienced in
2015 that was the first time uh that
something is happening and it's totally
different than than what we experienced
before 400
000 illegal migrants came to our
Southern borders and they wanted to just
come in and cross the border without any
permission and they just wanted to go to
Germany some of them wanted to stay but
many of them wanted to go to Germany
Sweden and other other countries and and
this was the point when prime minister
realized that that
you know the migration what we were
talking about it's completely different
uh from what we will experience in these
debates and and if we look around
um sub-Saharan Africa North Africa uh
Middle East Central Asia there are
millions of millions of people 10
millions and 10 millions of people
coming from overpopulated countries uh
and and they want to start a new life
somewhere and Europe that's the closest
uh continent so they want to start
without any permission they started they
want to start a new life in in Europe so
what was that like in 2015 I mean
everyone remembers the videos of just
watching people now we see these videos
now from Mexico into the United States
pretty much the same but so in essence
disorder it seemingly kind of happened
overnight it was really obviously
related to the war in Syria and
everything but what did you stop people
immediately do you like how yeah how
quickly the tricky thing was was that
the left was saying that that it's
mainly linked to the war in Syria so
it's a local conflict issue but uh but
we hosted people on our certain borders
from they were coming from more than 100
countries so not just Syria it was just
back at that time it was just 30 40
percent uh it's it's it's more broader
issue and we we mean we immediately
realized that if
um our country is not able to protect
the borders and to restore Law and Order
then then we are lost
and and we established the fans we built
the Border fans and it was a three
months operation
um and around
150 miles
um and and we stopped them and we
introduced the border control measures
where we stop everybody who is not have
the right to to enter and we get
threatened by the EU of course of course
since then that's a constant legal Court
War right
um right so what do they try to do I
mean they try to force you to just let
anyone in or what what are their
punishments really
um there were several uh punishment uh
the the latest is that they are
attacking us through the course so they
are
um in charge of the court system and the
institutions and and they try to block
over our legal mechanisms to
um to stop the people because the idea
is is that
that
if you are an illegal immigrant you are
not allowed to enter the country and
walk freely you have to apply for Asylum
and until the decision is made you are
not allowed to enter the territory of
the country because then you're gonna
disappear and
it will be impossible to find you
um and so and this is the basic idea of
what which according to their
understanding goes against
um the
humanitarian law requirements but it's
nonsense those humanitarian legal
requirements are out those are outdated
those are those are historical memories
um based on the Geneva Convention from
1951 back at that time the thing was
very different do you think they don't
even know what they're calling for or do
you think it is more nefarious than that
when you when you see this coming in
either through the ideas of wokeness or
quite literally the people walking
across the borders
oh no I think it's um it's it's it's a
political program of the left
and political program of of George
church and his open Society Foundation
because they think that European nations
they are they are threats of the future
so what they want to do is to
deconstruct these nations and how can
you deconstruct a nation so change you
have to change the population you have
to
um
let people in who are coming from a
different civilization and give them
citizenship as as soon as it is possible
they are not Christians they are mainly
Muslims they are they don't share our
values they have their own value system
they are very proud of it
um and and I don't want to judge this
kind of value system probably it works
in in Muslim societies
um or it definitely works in Muslim
societies but ours in our society where
the value system is is different so it's
it's I think and and those people if
they come in and they settle they they
establish parallel societies immediately
and they are supporting leftist liberal
of political forces with a huge majority
so for them it's a political program to
destroy the old European type of nation
states when when you talk to your
counterparts either in Germany or in the
UK places that let tons of people in
that have these parallel societies they
go man we're jealous you guys are a
little ahead of us on this thing we we
missed it
according to our understanding this is a
mistake what you can
what you can have only once
and if you you make that mistake and you
let millions of millions of people in
and you give them citizenship then it's
over
because
um
because
um because because you have no other
chance you have to live with uh with the
with those people and what our
counterparts are saying that um look you
are right
but our situation is different I have to
uh at least try to convince those voters
so I cannot cannot be the defender of
the Christian
civilization if
um 20 or 15 percent of my voters are
coming from a different background so
most probably you were right most
probably we made a bad decision we were
because we were only looking
to The Economic Consequences of decision
not the culture consequences but but
that's it so that's why we hungarians we
have to be and prime minister Urban is
in this sense the the most tough
anti-migration politician in in Europe
because because we have to be very tough
on on that issue once you commit this
mistake these people are in they are
part of society and the whole
equilibrium is changing if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about international issues
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our International playlist and if you
want to watch full interviews on a
variety of topics check out our full
episode playlist they're all right over
here and to get notified of all future
videos be sure to subscribe and click
the notification Bell